i think the losses
are so
painful
and so permanent
that the more he's lost the more
determined he becomes
never to lose again
and i think there's a little that of
that
that that has crept into
patrick mahomes he talked a little bit
along those lines i think earlier today
about how much it hurts and that the
pain
from losing
provides all the motivation that he'll
need for the rest of his career to win
if and when he gets back to that level
yeah i listened to all of my homes last
night mike and he talked about his dad
losing a world series and having to
rebound from that and he did talk about
it how much it
hurt
and i think that does motivate you never
to be back in that situation again
because it's the most painful thing you
can experience as an athlete is to get
all the way to the championship game
knowing what it takes to get there and
we talked a lot remember about the 49ers
talking about we just want to fast
forward to the super it doesn't happen
like that i mean it takes a lot
especially this year it took a lot for
these two teams just to get to that
point and then when you lose it it's
doubly devastating to to think about how
far you came to get there now you got to
start all over again it's not the same
team next year it's not the same
scenarios nothing's the same when you go
into the next year so you don't know
when you'll be back so you try to
cherish it when you win them and when
you lose them they certainly motivate
you and i do think that brady's been
motivated by that and you mentioned the
2017
that's ironic to me because that that
was probably the best team he ever
played on and one of the best teams in
nfl history and they didn't get it done
when it counted most and and so we still
think of that team as an awfully great
team but it didn't take that final step
to become
truly great and i think if they had we'd
be talking about that team is the
greatest of all time
well and some similarities between the
2007 patriots and the 2020 chiefs who
were
great all year long they had one loss in
the game that they were trying to win
they lost in week 17 but that was with
backups against the chargers here's
patrick mahomes with the benefit of
sleeping on it although i'm not sure how
much he slept last night discussing what
went wrong in super bowl 55.
i thought the guys did a good job i mean
we just we just didn't execute at a high
enough level i wasn't on the same page
with the receivers
on some plays there were some plays
where i got the line going in the wrong
direction um
and then and then at the end of the day
we just didn't we didn't execute and i
think that's the biggest thing and
um a lot of times it gets it gets it
gets put on that o-line um because i'm
scrambling around
but if we're not executing as far as me
making the right reads and getting the
ball out of my hand to the receivers on
time
then nothing's going to work so
they get they get that blame
sometimes but it's not deserved because
i mean a lot of it's on me and people
just don't see it that way
although sunday night shireen he did say
that sometimes the line blocked and
sometimes they let guys through and he
did spread some blame out it kind of
surprised me to hear him speak in those
terms because you don't
you don't expect to hear quarterbacks be
that blunt about the failings of others
on the offense other than themselves and
mahomes has a way where he can pretty
much say anything and it doesn't seem
like it would be insulting to anyone but
when you look at the words it's like oh
my gosh she was dangerously close to
throwing guys under the bus but we all
know there were issues with the
offensive line but we saw what happened
with the inability to connect with the
receivers down the field the tow
got aggravated at some point early in
the game mahomes ran for 497 yards
before throwing or getting sacked last
night almost five football fields of
running around hair on fire trying to
buy time
and there are many reasons why the
chiefs lost last night but mahomes
effort and ability
were not among the reasons he was
incredible last night he really was
doing everything he could to keep plays
alive find open guys guys were i don't
they weren't classic drops but there
were a lot of balls that could have
should have would have been caught that
weren't maybe they were so surprised the
ball got out of my home's hands before
he hit the ground but but i thought my
homes were spectacular as a player it
just didn't work for the chiefs
yeah everything that could have gone
wrong in that game mike went wrong for
the chiefs you look at the penalties in
95 yards set a super bowl record for
most penalties in the first half 95
yards six of those resulted in first
down the penalties killed them the
coaching killed them we haven't talked
nearly enough and i went on the
transcripts today to see if andy reid
was asked about it about his clock
management there at the end of the first
half and it reminded me of the eagles
patriots super bowl when the patriots
beat the eagles andy reid's clock
management at the end of the first half
and the end of the the second half
was abysmal and i thought it was bad him
calling those two timeouts because i
think the bucks were ready to go into
the locker room with with a one score
lead and andy reid called two timeouts
there stopped the clock and the bucks
obviously ended up getting the touchdown
out of that but all of those things went
wrong but back to my homes
yes he played well enough i think to to
win the game even though he didn't throw
a touchdown pass even though his passer
rating was the worst of his career but
you look at the offensive line being bad
his toe you know you wonder if those
things would have been different
you look at the drop passes you know
what if travis kelsey makes that third
down catch early what if they catch the
two touchdown passes it could have been
a completely different game but somebody
asked him in post-game about the
spider-man throw he made and i used the
picture in one of our posts of him like
levitating off the ground and throwing
the ball it's one of the greatest
incompletions in nfl history i i've
never seen an incompletion that great
how he got that ball off i don't know
but he played
pretty darn well to give the chiefs a
chance just not well enough with
everything else going on around the team
i mean when you're looking at his pass
reigning the super bowl last year wasn't
great he won mvp awards because the rest
of team around him didn't make all those
mistakes that they made this time night
yeah i mean people call that the
spider-man throw i've been calling it
the shortstop throw i mean that's his
baseball coming out of him that's the
the the ground ball deep in the hole
that he sprints back to getting in one
motion scoops it up and throws it to
first as he's diving laterally that's
why i said earlier today any dads out
there that want their boys to go up and
be quarterbacks get them playing
shortstop because the ability to throw
from every platform every arm angle
that's what makes mahomes great and and
he look i don't know how many times he's
going to be back he's now six behind
brady again that's a tough gap to close
especially while brady is still going
but uh mahomes
is never going to relent he's never
going to give up and i think when he's
back at the super bowl level again what
happened last night is going to provide
the same kind of fuel that it provides
for tom brady because as exhilarating as
it is to get to the top of the mountain
and plant the flag that's how much it
hurts to have one hand on the summit and
to be thrown all the way down to the
bottom of the mountain which is what
happened to the chiefs on sunday night
here's andy reid coach the chiefs on the
lessons that were learned from the 31-9
loss to the buccaneers
well it's tough to get here i'm proud of
the guys i mean
i mentioned that last night that
uh it's not an easy road getting back
that's why most teams
don't get back and
if you do most teams don't
you know it's not it's not always a
guaranteed win
um
they were better than we were yesterday
we've made too many too many mistakes
whether it was me calling the plays
putting guys in the right position
or
right down the line as you go so
um you make that many mistakes against a
good football team and they weren't
making as many mistakes and
you're not going to win at this level so
uh you gotta
you know you gotta come into these games
you got to be sharp
well you got to be sharp and you got to
be ready and we praise andy reid all the
time shireen for his ability when he has
two weeks to prepare for a game to have
his guys ready to go and they rarely
lose and they didn't have to travel down
to tampa the weekend before they weren't
distracted by the usual super bowl
things that occur there was another
distraction we'll we'll discuss that may
have affected things in the latter days
but you know this defense played
incredibly well and the team that won
the regular season meeting in super
bowls involving rematches from a game
that was played during that regular
season window they're now six and eight
which proves that not only does it not
matter at a certain level it's a bit of
a detriment because
you you you beat them hey we beat them
we can beat them again well you're six
and eight and i know it's different
teams different years different eras but
there's something to be said for
that that that edge that you may lose
when you've already played a team you've
already beaten a team what do you do the
second time around do you do the same
thing you did the first time around do
you change it what you did last time
worked but yeah they know you did it so
you're gonna do something else and i
think it it creates another factor
another complication another thing to
worry about for a super bowl game that
entails plenty of different things for
teams to worry about shireen
if the buccaneers had not played the
chiefs in week 12 i feel fairly
confident that the chiefs would have won
this game because the bucks figured some
things out in the last three quarters i
think it was important too mike that
that game was late in the season it was
week 12. it wasn't week one or week two
or week three it was week 12. so they
they had seen those matchups they knew
how to defend them and they figured some
things out in the last three quarters of
that game when you look at
tyree kill was on pace for almost a
thousand yards in that one game after
the first quarter and he had over 200
yards ended up with 269 i think it was
and three touchdowns they did a better
job in the last three quarters i think
they figured out a lot of things in that
game that helped them in this game they
made a lot of changes obviously
defensively but i think it helped them
offensively too and i just think if they
hadn't played the chiefs in that week i
just don't know that they would have won
this game
that's a great point that's a great
point because
whatever the buccaneers did
to adjust helped slow down the chiefs in
the regular season matchup patrick
holmes was more than halfway to 700
passing yards in the first half of that
game
and they made the adjustments they got
away from single coverage on tyree kill
and yeah you carry that into the rematch
and i don't know what the chiefs were
expecting sims looked at the film today
and we'll be talking that about that
more tomorrow on pft live i think what
he saw was the chiefs thought they could
just do what they did the last time
around and the buccaneers were ready for
it this time and you know it's one thing
to have great players but you still have
to put great players in the right spot
in order to get the most out of their
talents you know when you look at the
combined performance of tyra killing
travis kelsey that's 206 yards that's
great but kelsey had some garbage time
catches down the middle and run with the
ball after the fact i mean for tyreek
hill to be limited to 73 yards when he
was such a huge factor in the regular
season matchup i agree with you it
worked out very well that that game
happened when it did and that was the
spark going into the bye week and what
did the buccaneers do after that bye
week following the loss of the chiefs
they won
four regular season games no five
regular season games to end that portion
of the schedule and then four more
in the postseason uh wait four and four
i'm sorry it was four and four eight my
math my math sucks
eight four plus four
is eight yeah yeah we mean eight anyway
uh so eight so bottom line is uh yeah i
agree with you i think that the fact
that the buccaneers got to see the
chiefs when they did was more of an
advantage for the buccaneers than the
chiefs
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports